hey guys my name is just McDonald it's
the twelfth of me and you're watching
games but news let's talk the video game
yeah I have to slide it that a bunch of
multiplayer games have had their day and
they'll be taking them offline next
month june thirtieth will be the day
when the following games lose online
functionality so if you're still playing
games like battlefield two on pc crysis
two on pc or neverwinter nights 2 then
don't expect to be able to get your
multiplayer on anymore hey have said
that the decision has been made in
relation to the shutdown of games by
explaining unfortunately due to the
technical challenges and concerns about
the player experience we do not have a
solution at this time online services
for EA games on the game spy platform
will be closed down at the end of June
you can find a full list of games
affected on gamespot but they extend to
battlefield 2142 command and conquer red
alert 3 and medal of honor allied
assault let me know if you're bothered
by the news next up Diablo 3 ultimate
evil edition will be making its way over
to ps4 and xbox one this August Blizzard
confirmed that Reaper of souls will come
to Sony and Microsoft current and last
gen consoles on August the 19th the xbox
one and ps4 versions are set to retail
for 59 99 whereas if you'd prefer to
pick it up on xbox 360 or ps3 it'll set
you back just 39 99 if you already had a
console edition of the game you will be
able to keep your characters ps3
characters are transferable to pierce
poor while xbox 360 characters can be
moved to Xbox one should you want to do
that lastly watchdog sure won't be
disappointing you on the ps4 as it's set
to run at 1080p and 60 frames per
seconds on Sony's console Sony confirmed
the news on playstation com by writing
hack everything as you make your way
through Chicago's underground as you
experience watchdogs in a way that only
ps4 can provide at 60 frames per second
in 10
p so they've since removed that last
line from their site in addition they've
added that the four exclusive
PlayStation missions are timed
exclusives and that they'll also be
available on PC though the PlayStation
content does come with a hacking boost
pack and a white suit so I guess there's
that let me know what platform you're
intending to play watchdogs on and why
in that commenting section down below or
if you prefer you can chat to me on my
twitter where i'm at just mcdonald those
are all the things that i have to say be
today but be sure to join me again same
time tomorrow for another dose of music
goodness until then be sure to drop me
every thought you've ever had in that
commenting section and I'll see you soon